草を採った意味はパチェッサと言ってたんですけども
これは巧みな人は花を育てて咲かせるという
そういう意味ですか  一応そういう意味なんです
パチェッサというのは別な
辞書を引いちゃうと別な単語が来るんですけど
熟するっていう意味でしょ
熟するっていうより成果を出すっていうことですよ
まあそこら辺はですね
まあ単純な意味でいいんです
はい  先ほど道徳のお話に入る時に
私はあまり人に迷惑はかけませんっていう
その人がいるけれども
そのこと自体がすごく迷惑だっていうことをその人は分かってないんだっていうようなお話をズバッとされたんですけれども
それは結局生きてるだけでもいろんな人のお世話になったり
迷惑をかけているってことをその人は気がついてないっていうことをおっしゃってたんでしょうか
ちょっと意味が分かりにくかったので
別にまあ単純な言葉ですよ
そんなに真剣に考えなくて
だからお前黙っているということでね
迷惑かけないんだったら
迷惑は言葉さえもというぐらいで取っちゃえばいいんじゃないんですか
偉そうにばったりして
別に僕もうすごい真剣な意味で私は言ったわけじゃない
冗談で言ったんですね
それが迷惑やと 私は誰にも迷惑かけてませんよと
だからそれが迷惑や 迷惑でしょう
結局は まあそんなに深い意味あるっていうことじゃないです
深い意味で言うならば
もうみんなにお世話になって生きてるんだから
誰にも迷惑かけてないとかすごい傲慢でしょうね
傲慢な態度を取ることほど迷惑あるんですかね
本当にありがとうございます
おかげさまで助かりましたというふうに生きていた方がいいのに
それこそ迷惑でしょうに
あの態度 まあそんなもんで
はい  先ほど殺生したいというのは人間の普遍的な欲望であるというお話がありましたけれども
その戒律というのは 人間のそういった普遍的な欲望をその抑えるということなんでしょうか
抑えるでは足らないんですよ
自分のその気持ちを破って成長しなくちゃいけないんですね
抑えるのは苦しいんですよ
殺したいのに殺せないでいるということはね
その気持ちを壊すんです
このアディ スーパーという言葉をつける場合はね
普通の世間ではただ抑えるだけなんですよ
嘘をついたんだけど もう抑えましょうと
その時もやっぱりやばいんだからっていうぐらいのことでつければついちゃうでしょ
全然役に立たない それぐらい程度の道徳は
これは超人を作ろうという世界なんです
だからこの人間だけではなくて
どんな生命も やっぱり生命と言えば
もう他の生命を壊して生きるシステムですよ
だって我々は生きてるものを食べなきゃ生きていられないでしょうに
たとえ菜食主義者だと言ったっても
植物を食べてるんだからね
石は食べられないし 砂も食べられないしね
命がないものと言えば
ただ水だけでしょ 体に入られるのは水と空気
それ以外全部命なんですよ
だから生命たるものはみんなね
他の生命を奪ってますよ
そのそのレベルで殺生がブッダがこの悟りの戒律にして
だからアディというスーパーという言葉をつけているんです
普通の道徳とは違うと
普通の道徳だったら殺生しなきゃいいんです
その程度では我々は心の次元破って
人間の次元を破って この悟った覚者という超人にはならないんです
だから覚者は人間じゃないんです
もう生命でもない もうもう制覇しちゃったんです
生命と言っちゃえば もうどうしても殺生しなきゃ生きていられないという罠の中にいるんですね
はい そうしますと 我々はその生きている限り
そういった境地には境地という言葉が適切かどうか分かりませんが
至れないということになりますか？ そう
論理的にはね 論理的にはそうなるんです
それでお釈迦様はこの道は順番でやるもんやと
段取りありますよと 安心しなさいと
段取りでやってみなさいと
確実にできますと だから
ただ 今私が言ったのは
純粋に説法で この何と言いますか
教理学というかね この専門的な解説なんですよ
それであんまり皆様話を理解しようという気持ちもなさそうだから
だったらもう言っちゃうと
別に聞いてくれなくても
聞いてくれると私も心配してね
理解できるレベル調整するんだからね
今はあまり心配しないんです
聞いてくれないのはわかっているんだからね
だから自分ではもう完全に解説しましたという自己満足
だから今日の解説は このブッダの言葉はブッダを思った通りの解説
ブッダがこの意味で言ったんだよという
このブッダの生の考え方を皆様に紹介した
それがそのまま実行はできません
今の説明はどちらかというと
悟った人の境地を説明しただけで
我々は悟ってないんだから
次の問題はどうやって悟れるのかということはなんですね
それの質問にお釈迦様は安心しなさい
段取りありますから 何に何にしてもと
段取りでやってくださいと
段取りっていうのは 例えば今
殺生が問題でしたでしょ
我々は自分にできる範囲で殺生を守ってみる
守ってみると いろんな壁にぶつかるんです
その小さな小さな壁を乗り越えていく
だから完全な殺生になるまで壁があるはずなんです
それで なんか知らないうちに自分が完全な境地に立ってるんです
だから遠く見てはいけない
過去を振り返ってはいけない
前にある階段をだけ登ればいいんです
今この階段にいるんだと
じゃあ上１個あるんだからこれ登ってやるぞと
もう１個あるんで じゃあこれも登ってやるぞと
それでいたところで もう階段がないんだというところになるんです
あ 全部登ったと それで山を登る人は後ろを振り返えちゃうと登れなくなっちゃうんです
頂上を見ると登れなくなるんです
これは無理やと思っちゃうんです
そういうことで段取りがあるんです
よくわかります  もう一つは論理的な質問だから論理的に答え出します
この生きている限りは悟れないのではないかというね
論理的にそうなんですよ
しかし その論理に問題あります
生きることって そんなにすごいんですかと
だから生きることは最高な幸せであってという前提があるならば成り立つ答えなんですよ
仏教は生きることは苦だと言ってるんだからね
だから本当は仏教でそうしては成り立たないんです
生きることは喜びではないんだと
苦労ばっかしだと この瞬間でももう安らぎがないでしょうと
なんとかうまくいったとしたっても
病気になる恐れもあるし
事故を起こす恐れもあるし
ビクビクして生活しなくちゃいけない
いくら頑張っても何かに遭遇する
だって皆様に親がいるでしょうに
親が死にますよ これ楽しくないんですよ
生きている時は無視しちゃいますけど
亡くなった瞬間でものすごい悲しいんですよ
こんな経験 誰でも味わわなくちゃいけないしね
だからもう生きるということはそんなもんであって
そんな尊くて 必ずも生きていなくちゃいけないという態度は仏教ではないんです
だからもうそういう風なすごい強烈に言うんです
どんな道徳項目にしたっても
同じ理屈は成り立つんです
例えば嘘をつくなよと言ってもね
生きている上ではということが出てくるんです
それは仏教はこれは理屈じゃないよと
私は生きることは素晴らしいであって
人間のゴールであると言ってないんだよと
生きることは破って乗り越えることがゴールやと言ってるんだから
それは破らなくちゃいけないんです
だから生きることはドゥッカというね
あの４つの真理の１番目はドゥッカ苦しみってことですからね
そこから言ってるんです
はい まだ質問ございますか？あのすごい実践不可能に喋ったっても
あの何のことなく実践できます
だからお釈迦様おっしゃったこのこれがもう人間に人間が考えたこともない
人間に発見もできない
ものすごい超越した世界であるというところは
いつでもその通りにあるんです
それがそれちょっと言いたかったんだよ
私は だからこの瞑想してみたっても
やっぱり普通の世界とはものすごい違うというね
言っても何か別な次元世界に入るわけでもないんです
全て破るんです 破って乗り越える
はい それではまたいろいろ質問ではなくても意見でもよろしいです
今の考え方と同じ  先生
はい  悟った人というのは業はもう作らない
作らない 悟ったお釈迦様はもう悟った人にはもうただもう単語ないと言ってますから
お釈迦様にある人を聞いたでしょう
あなたは 何でしたっけ
お釈迦様を見てあるバラモン人がえらく驚いちゃって
これでは人間ではないでしょうと
誰かと知らない ただお釈迦様が歩いているのをあるバラモン人が見たんですね
見ただけでこの人びっくりしちゃって
こんな人のないところで一人で歩いているこの人は絶対人間ではありませんと
自分の宗教から考えたら
もう絶対的な神様は梵天だからね
おそらく人間の様子を見るために梵天が神様が降りてるんじゃないかなと
だからこのお釈迦様の姿を歩き方を見ただけでも
これって何？もうそういうすごい不思議に思ったんですね
で とにかく本人だけ見つけたんだからね
一応会ったんです 会って
もう梵天神様やと思ってるんだからね
随分丁寧に礼をして あなたは梵天でしょうか？と聞いた
いきなりブッダは いえ
違いますよと 梵天でなきゃ神でしょうと
こんな姿だったらということで
別に肉体のことじゃない
この何にもとらわれない心の波動が感じちゃったんですね
だから いえ 神でもありませんと
そうやっていろいろこれではないか
これではないかと聞くんです
そうじゃないと だったら何か神霊でしょうかと
いえ 私も神霊でもありませんよと
言うと もうネタ切れちゃったんですね
切れて ではそちらは人間でしょうかと
いえ 人間ではありませんよというんですね
お釈迦様は ですから 何者でもありませんということなんです
で バラモン人がもう頭がもう混乱しちゃって
そちら何をしてるんですかと
梵天かと聞いたら 違う
神かと聞いたら違いますと言うわ
人間か神霊かと聞いたらまた違うという
では人間でしょうか？というと
また違いますと言うと
私はそなたのことをどう理解すればいいんでしょうか？と言ったら
私はなぜ梵天でないとかって
梵天が持っている欲は私にないんだと
いわゆる梵天というのは生命だから
たとえ神様と言ったっても生命だから
生命でいるんだから煩悩があるんです
生きてきたいという そんなのはないんだからね
梵天ではありませんと
神と言ったっても 神が持っている煩悩もないんだから
もう神でもないんだと
神霊でもないんだと 人間かと聞いたって人間持ってる感情やら煩悩という関わりもないんだよと
だから人間でもないんだと
だったらそちらはどなた？そなたはどちらでしょうかと
私はブッダですよと いわゆる覚者ですよと
肉体的には歴史的にはお釈迦様は人間ですよ
悟ったらもう生命ではありませんというね
もう乗り越えていると
ただ命が終わるまで肉体を持っているだけの話です
勝利者なんですね 他アイデアございますか？ すいません
実質の世界だと それでは悟ったお釈迦様でも食事はなさるわけですよね
それはあれですか あの
布施を受けたものだからいいということですか？自分では別に食べたわけじゃない
お釈迦様でも食事をなさるわけですかね
食事って他の生命を食べてることになるわけです
だから その食後 食後食事をしなかったわけじゃないだろうと
あるいはお釈迦様だって道歩いてたら
道に歩いてる蟻を踏み潰してるかもしれないじゃないか
屁理屈の世界で申し訳ないですけど
だからそれは要するにその意図を持って殺してはならないと
殺意を持って殺生してはならないという因果となれば
なんとなく一貫するんですけども
食事をするけれども それは自分が
自分がというか お布施でもって出家しておられるわけですから
お釈迦様はお食べになるものは
例えばお百姓さんが作った米であれば
その生命を食べていることになるんじゃないか
それを一貫してそうじゃないっていうためには
布施を受けてというか
自分が殺意を持って調理したものではないというふうにしないと
その屁理屈の世界ではなんか一貫しないような気もするんですけど
やっぱ殺意を持って殺生はしない
あるいは無意味な殺生はしないっていうんだったら
なんとなく我々凡人もわかるんですが
その辺がちょっとまあ
うーん そういう思考には返事するのはもうできませんね
だから自分の世界の概念はあれこれといくら組み立てても
この真理の世界には関係なくなっちゃうんです
その質問も ただ我々の価値観でごちゃごちゃ考えただけのことであって
その価値観一つも仏教ではないんですけどね
こうだからこうする ああだからこうするという世界ではありません
ブッダの世界は とにかく一般の人には全くもわからないという心情です
心情というものもないんです
普通の人には ブッダはどういうふうなことを考えて
どういうふうにとか それは考えることは無理不可能だからやめなさいと
お釈迦様は言うんです
もし疑いあったら調べなさいと
私は嘘をついているとかね
欲があるのかあるかないかとかね
悟っていると言ってますけど
本当なのかとかね それは疑いあったら調べてもいいんだけど
ブッダを理解しようということだけはやめなさいと
で ブッダを試す場合は
お釈迦様が試す方法まで教えてあげるんです
で それが人のこの修行を考えて言ってるんです
例えば悟ってない人々は悟らなくちゃいけない
悟りって何なのかというと
貪り 怒り 欲っていうのはもう何でしたっけ
欲と怒りと無知っていうのは完全に絶すことなんですね
それでブッダが悟っているという
悟っているという場合
欲がないはずなんです
それであなた調べてくださいと
その場合は自分持ってる欲が尺度なんですよ
自分に欲があるんだから
自分持ってる欲と合わせてみると
あんたはブッダにはないと発見するんだよと
しかし 欲のない人の心境はどういうことかというと
それはわかりませんよ
理解できません 欲の世界では
それでさらに詳しくお釈迦様は説明してあげて
欲のある人はこういう言葉は喋れません
欲のある人だったらこういう言葉を喋る
ブッダがこういう言葉を喋る
欲のある人ならこういうことは喋られないんです
欲のある人だったら こういうこういう行動をする
しかし ブッダはそういう行動はしません
そういう風にしかあなた方には私を調べることはできないということで
そこら辺で調べてくださいと
お釈迦様の生き方と お釈迦様の話しことと考えることとか
そういう点で貪瞋痴があるかないかと
とことん調べなさいと
その時でも結局は調べる尺度は自分なんですね
いとも簡単に自分とはものすごい違うと発見できます
発見できたら まあそれで一時的に仮説的に決めるしかないんだ
ブッダが悟っているんだと
それもただの仮説的なというか
仮説と言わないね まあ一応推測みたいなことで
それからあんた方もこの方法をやってみてくださいと
この方法をやると あんた方の心からも貪り
怒り 欲 無知が消えてしまうよと
消えてしまったところでわかりますよと
なるほどと ブッダは悟っているんだと
だから一般の人は推測でいかなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様にある信者さんが肉の料理を作ってお布施したんです
それがジャイナ教の修行者たちにバレちゃったんです
仏教とジャイナ教のみんなほとんど一緒にいたんだからね
お互い何の秘密もあったわけじゃないんです
宗教は違うんだけど で
食事はもう前の日で徹夜して作りますから
準備も大変でしょうし
だから準備をして徹夜して料理作っている
これはジャイナの人々はもう分かったんですね
明日はお釈迦様に肉の料理のお布施になるんだと
でお釈迦様は別に文句言うことなくもう召し上がるんですよ
それでこのジャイナの修行者たちがね
ブッダも本当にブッダって言いながら
自分のために動物をさばいてそれで作ったものは何のこともなく食べたんだと
それって何を何のことですかと
と批判したんです 批判しちゃったら
この信者さんがお布施した人が誰でもなくこのジーヴァカというお医者様なんですね
治療のお医者様で コーサラ国王の個人的な医者で
ブッダとサンガの治療もしていたんです
だから彼が医者だからね
お釈迦様にすごい体の健康やらなんだかんだも考えて
適切な料理作ってあげただけなんです
しかし ジーヴァカさんがこれで困っちゃったんですね
あまりに批判しているんだからされているんだから
自分だけ批判されるのはいいんだけど
お釈迦様にを批判しているんだから
ジーヴァカ医者がすごくそれ気に入らないんですね
で お釈迦様にそれ言ったんですね
こういうことになっているんだと
むちゃくちゃ言われてるんだと
そしたらお釈迦様の答えは
もうブッダもブッダのお弟子たちも
例えばこちらに座っている時は
全ての生命が幸福でありますようにという気持ちでいるんだよと
それも前の方向 前方 無限に
生命たるものがあれば
皆ことごとく幸福でありますように
後ろの方 無限に 生命たるものがあれば幸福でありますようにと
右側 左側 それから下 上という六方ですね
そういうふうに六方にも住んでいる一切の生命が幸福でありますようにという気持ちで
その念で生きているんだと
歩く時でも同じですよと
どこかに行く時でも同じ気持ちでいるんだよと
そこで信者さんが自分の幸福のために
自分たちの孤独を背負うために何か料理を作ってくれると
また同じ気持ちで一切の生命が幸福でありますようにという気持ちで
それは食べますということ
これは食べませんと言っちゃうと
あげた人がまたね その人の得にならないしね
だからお釈迦様が だから自分が作ってくれた肉料理を食べたことが慈悲の行為であるとということは言ってないんですけど
そういうふうな気持ちで食べてるんだと
それで そのような人に生命を殺している
殺させているというのは正しいとあなたは思いますかと
その批判は それはもう自由さんがもうとんでもないんだと
そういう話はと そういうことですからっていうことで終わったんです
だからまあ そんなもんでしょう
あまり説明はしにくいんですけど
今日はテーマではないしね
まあもうあまりそういうポイントに集中したくないんですけど
お釈迦様が何かご飯食べたんだからといって
やっぱり殺生してるんだという話にはなりません
私もそう思いますが 要するに本当にその悟りの境地に至るためには
出家するということが
出家しなければならないと
これはつらぬきの方針だと
出家しないで悟った人々もいますけどね
出家は必要な条件としてどこにも書いてはないんですね
学ぶ人は悟れるという話ですから
学べばいいでしょうと
どんどん思考を開発していけばいいのです
この段取りを忘れる 忘れて考える人々は
もう頭で考えて やっぱり出家しなきゃ無理やとかね
決めたりはする  その人々にお釈迦様は出家しなさいと言うんですよ
もう ではなくて きちんと段取りを取って努力する人には
それなりにしっかりとアドバイスをする
論理的には出家しなきゃ悟り開けないということは成り立たないんです
それで ああそうか 在家でいいかということになる
違うんですよ やっぱり難しいそれが
煩悩はなくす世界だからね
出家でも在家でもない
出家したっても結局は煩悩だらけで執着だらけでね
気持ち悪いだけの話で
何かを捨てて何かを掴まるんだから
捨てた人は立派であって
捨てる人は 何かを捨てて何かを取るんだったらね
どうったことはないんで
そんなのは だからこれが結構大変です
考えるのは だから 裁量でできるかないけないか
出家しなきゃできるかできないかという話ではありません
出家してもできない人はいる
だから 裁量で頑張る 相当頑張ってもできない人もいる
なぜできないのかというと
その人は捨てるということはしないのです
財産があっても捨てるという気持ちがなければ
捕らわれませんというね
家族がいても捕らわれませんと
そこで脱出することが成り立つのです
食事の場合は やっぱり命
食物でも命ですからね
だから出家する人々には料理作って食べるなよということにしているのです
料理作るということの
食べる時は命は食べないんですよ
生きたまんまで栄養になりません
物質でないと 命がちゃうと危ないんですよ
魚生で食べちゃって そのまんまでお腹の中に行っちゃう
行っちゃうと 冗談じゃないんです
これ大変体が壊れるんだと
栄養になりません だから
虎であろうと誰であろうとも
生きたものは食べないのです
鳥とかはね もう飲み込んじゃいますけど
生きたまんまで 蛇もそうでしょうしね
でも 蛇が飲み込んだカエルがお腹の中でじっと元気に生きているんだったらね
これ何年経っても栄養になりませんよ
そういうことで 人間にしても
食べる食事ということになってくると
もう命はないのです でも材料は食事にする
材料の場合は命があるのですね
そういうことで この調理するなよっていうことにするのです
しかし そんなことをゴチャゴチャ言うと
もう極端論になっちゃって
ちょっと成り立たなくなりますから
そこら辺はジャイナ教と違って
結構 論理的な理性のところで説明は終了しちゃうんです
しかし 論理的にも だから答えは解脱するしか方法がないでしょうというところにするんです
解脱することには全面的に攻めちゃうんです
解脱もしない しないで完全な生き方をするそうと言えば無理と
まず完全な生き方をするぞと決めなさいと
そうしちゃうと無理は見えてくる
摂取をしないと決めた途端
無理ということは見えてくるはずなんです
だったら解脱しなさいと
それで解脱を目指してチャレンジをする
それには段取りが成り立つ
だから決して頭でっかちの理屈というわけじゃないんです
だから料理してはいけないっていうのは
これまた出家だけの話で
在家は料理しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでアンタ摂取してるんだっていうことを言っちゃうと
もう話にならなくなっちゃうんですね
その時は在家の人々にも心構えを教えてあげる
肉体を維持するために食べなさいと
ただ肉体を維持するためだと
これが 肉体維持して生きていて何やと
何の意味もないんだと
だから借りた命でさっさと煩悩をなくすことはメイン仕事に
本職にしなさいよと 食うことは本職じゃないんだと
本職をするため やるために支えにしなさいと
そうしちゃうと完璧なんです
生き方は 仕事のために生きるとかね
その世界で 仕事のために生きるんじゃないんです
家族を守るために生きるんじゃないんで
そんなのは嘘でしょうし
私はやっぱり生きていて家族を守らなくちゃいけない
そんなこと言ったっても
死んじゃったらどうするんですかね？死ぬ時は死ぬでしょうに
自分の国でももう七万人かな？もうそんな瞬間で死んじゃったんだから
みんな家族ありましたけどね
家族あるんだから このお父さんは津波に流してはあきませんとか
そんな話ないでしょうに
小さな子供いるんだから
このお母さんは死んだら困りますよと
そういう話にならない
死ぬ時は死ぬ だから家族のために生きるっていうのは
単なるもう言葉のごまかしで
あまり意味のないことだ
仕事があるんだからとかね
何とかとか言ったってもの一つも本職じゃない
死ぬ時は死ぬ みんな だったら死ぬ前にやっておかなくちゃいけないことっていうのは
人 せっかく人間に生まれたんだから
無知で死ぬなよと 汚れた心で死ぬなよと
知を開発して死ねと 生命次元を乗り越えて死ねと
だからそれが本職であって
自分の至るべきゴールであると
そのゴールに至るまで必要なものは
もう副産 何と言いますか
二次的に それぞれ適当にやるだけの話
そうすると罪のない生き方なんです
そこでないと 誰の生き方でも結局は罪を犯している生き方なんです
だからこの人生の目的をね
入れ替えないと 何のために生きているのかといえば
これ生きることをやめるために生きているんだよということにならないと
生き続けることをやめてやると
その境地を経験するために生きているんだと
いわゆる解脱するために生きているんだということについて言えば
なぜ食べているのかというと
ものすごく簡単にわかります
なぜ仕事に行くのかというと
ものすごく簡単に理解できます
その場合は その場合は仕事は罪にならない
料理作って食べても罪にならない
解脱しなくちゃいけないんだから
だから今は死ぬわけにはいかないということで
ちょっと支えてもらう
そういうすごい これはすごい軽いというか
精神的にものすごい穏やかな気分で生きていられますよ
ストレスはたまりません
悔しいというような気持ちになりません
仕事は乗っ取られたとかね
何て悔しいとは それ一つも成り立たない
すごく軽く生きていられます
それで そういう気持ちでいる人は
最期でいても罪のない生き方ですよ
その人生のモットーを変えない限りは
もう保証なし 何やっても罪になる
ありがとうございます
はい どうぞ  先ほどの水に魂があるというのは
水 水に魂があるから飲んじゃいけないというのは
仏教徒としてはちょっとよく理解ができないんですけれども
あの このブッダの時代も
ジャイナ教と仏教徒っていうのはかなり対立をして
対立っていうか まあ対立していたんでしょうか
マハヴィールとお釈迦様は結構近くにいらっしゃったと思いますけど
思想的にかなり食い違いがあって
やっぱりいろいろ意見が全然合わなくてということはすごくあったんでしょうか
意見がほとんど合わなかったんですよ
ものすごい違いますから
仏教はもうジャイナの教えはもうもう全く意味のないという態度を取っていたし
しかし お互いの生き方はどちらかというとほとんど似ているんだから
仲良く一緒にはいたんです
だからそれはあくまでもこの心理の世界でお互い宗教は違うんだと
ブッダはどちらかというとジャイナ教を非難したり貶したりはしなかったんです
いつでもほとんど一緒だからね
心配してあげたんです
あなた方は本当に可哀想やと
なぜかというと ジャイナ教の方々でもものすごい超真面目なんですよ
ものすごい真剣に苦行していたんです
だからもう私もジャイナ教の人に会うと
なんか全然嫌な気分にならないんですよ
なんか昔から知ってる人に会ったような感じで
ずいぶん親切に仲良くニコニコと喋ったりする
それでその人々は自分の生き方とか説明するでしょうね
否定もできないんですけど
どこかで大変だな この人々は
というね そういう心配の気持ちは今にも生まれてくるんです
例えばインドに仏石あるところは全部ジャイナ教に乗っ取られてますけどね
これヒンドゥー教の寺院を建てて
なんだこの人々と思っちゃいますけど
ジャイナブッダが聖地なのにジャイナ教の寺院があると
ジャイナ教に乗っ取られてるんだということで終わっちゃうんです
あ ここはジャイナ教に乗っ取られてるんだとか
あ しょうがない こちら仏教徒はいないんだから
そういう疑問なんです
だってずっと一緒にいたならば
仏教徒とか消えちゃうとジャイナ教になるのは
前の流れでしょ だから宗教的には全く違うんです
ジャイナ教はすべて魂だと言っているんです
実体として 形あるものには魂があると
魂があるんだから形が作れるんだと
そういうことで 水に形があるでしょ
ある  じゃあ水を飲んじゃいけないっていうことは
どうしていたんですか？ 魂があるんだからなんですよ
お湯を飲んでたんですか？ そうそう
お湯だったらいいんです
だから成り立たないんですよ
そういうところをお釈迦様は笑っちゃうんですよ
だから物質に関わるなよということを徹底的に言っていたんです
あんた方はあまりにも物質に関わりすぎだと
心 心みなさいよと 魂みたいな変わらない実体あるわけじゃないんだと
魂は変わらない実体といえば
説得も成り立たんでしょうにと
例えば動物を殺しても魂は殺せないんだから別にいいんじゃないんですかね
だから魂論というのはものすごい危険なんです
ヨーロッパでも苦しんでる動物平気で殺すでしょう
人も殺すんですよ やっぱり苦しんでるんだから楽にしてあげるぞと
何様のつもりですかね
苦しんだってもしょうがないでしょうに
死ぬ時は死ぬんだから放っておけばいいんです
だからこの なんでヨーロッパの方でこの
まあ苦しいんだから早く死なせましょうということになるのかというと
これ魂なんですよ まあ死んでも大丈夫
魂が天国に行くんだから
そんな理屈を出すと お釈迦様の反論は
だったらお前ら早く死んでくださいとお互いに殺し合いやって
だって一日でも早く天国行った方が楽でしょうと
そういう反論なの だから魂論
我がある 魂がある これがものすごい恐ろしい非道徳的な概念なんです
それを持ってくると道徳が成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
だから他宗教は魂霊魂信じながら道徳を語ってるんですよ
かなり無理があるんですよ
だからかなり無理があって
そこら辺をこの矛盾を何とかしようと必死で苦労しているんです
イスラム教にしたっても
自殺はものすごい大罪なんですよ
なのに魂が信じると信じているんだから
何爆弾？あれ 自爆やるんです
無茶でしょうに やってることで
言ってることは 魂は永遠なると言いながら
タイでイスラム人がいっぱい死にましたからね
あの津波はイスラム人狙ってきたような感じですけど
自分の国にイスラム人いっぱい住んでるところのかなりもう全部旋回しましたからね
失礼な言い方ですけど
もう人は誰でも命ですからね
それはもう死んでいいわけじゃないんですけど
で もうタイではね もうだからあれは人間生き残されてる人々の健康を考えて
もうビシビシビシと遺体を燃やしちゃうんですよ
タイは仏教の国だからね
こんな遺体って燃えせましょうということで
そんなにどうったことはないんです
すごい論理的に考えちゃうんです
それでイスラム人がなんつう
なんたることをでしょ
ちゃんと埋葬しなくちゃと
私がもうあなた方の魂はそんな程度でしょうかと
火に焼けるもんかと ヨーロッパでも同じ考え方で
丁寧に埋葬する 永遠に眠るとか何とか言って
あの人々は皆イスラム教も同じ考え方で
この世紀末の時は全て死んだ人々は蘇ってくると
だからちゃんと寝かしてあげないとね
だから死んだわけじゃなくて
寝ている 神様が呼ぶんだから
呼ぶんだから 世紀末の時
呼ぶ時は起きてきます
そこまで寝かすっていうこと
言ったとしても実際に腐ってるんですけど
それ言ったらイスラム人の人は私に笑っちゃうんで
あんた方にわからないんだと
そんなことはね 目に見えることしか信じないんだからと
すごくからかわれちゃったんです
世紀末の時はみんな生きてた姿で起きてくるんだと
あんた方は神様の力知らないんだから
そういうだけやと 実際はもう骨まで土になりますけど
あれはカルシウム入ってるんだから
結構もう残りますけど
カルシウムだから石でしょ
でなきゃ骨も 砂になる
土になるし それでヨーロッパで堂々と丁寧に埋葬しちゃって
ヨーロッパにある皆様すごい見学する巨大なキャテドラルとか全部墓でしょ
みんなもうそこじゃ それで場所がないんだから今は火葬する
それでキリスト教はうまく定義変えるんです
あ 僕の火で燃やしても魂は燃えませんから
では火葬しましょうと
何ヘリクツかと これはもう場所がなくなったんです
そういうことで まあやっぱり私が言いたいのは
みんなこの道徳モラルの場合はかなり矛盾にあって苦労するんだっていうこと
だから永遠不滅なものはありえないんだから
ちょっと理屈で考えたって
あるっていうことは ある条件があるんだからあるんでしょうに
永遠不滅な魂が私の体に入り込んじゃっているならば
えらい異物で 何の影響も受けないんだから
でも私はっていうのはそうじゃないでしょうに
人にもうからかわれると嫌な気分になるし
馬鹿にされちゃうと腹が立つし
もうそっちが自分が変わっているのに
変わらないもの何かあるのかと
何もないでしょうに だから変わらないと言ったら存在もしないという意味なんです
だからもうそんな妄想概念を持ってくると道徳がなくなっちゃいますよ
この世の中から 生命をお互いに殺し合いやってる生き方だから道徳がないとおっかないんですよ
どうせ死ぬんだから 道徳がどうしても必要なんです
我々はどうしても人を何て言いますか
騙したいんだから 人を騙して自分の利益得たいでしょうに
だから嘘をつくなよという道徳が必要なんですよ
だから商売できますよ
嘘をついてもいいということにしちゃうと商売できんだから
商売やってる人はみんな嘘を言ってますよ
でもかなり気をつけて嘘言ってるんです
だからもう道徳が必要なんです
もう絶対条件で必要なんです
例えば嘘を言ってもいいということを考えてください
その想定して考えてください
嘘を言ってもいいと それだったら店で売ってるものを買う
この薬飲んだら美容にいい
健康に もう体重は減ると
奇跡の薬やと言っても買う
で みんな買って飲むでしょ
健康美容の薬などは 実際飲んでみたら結局は逆効果でしょ
[笑い]すごい健康が崩れちゃうでしょ
あれはいいところは全部女性に売ってるんだからいいんですよ
あんなの男性に売っちゃうとものすごい早く死んじゃいますよ
女性の体はね すごい頑丈だから
もうどんな毒飲んだってもそう簡単には死にません
まあとにかく私は言いたいのは
例えば人がもうすごい奇跡の薬が開発しましたとか言っても
嘘言ってもいいなら信じられませんね
それで嘘言ってはいけないんだと
法律で裁くんだと言われているんだから
もしかするとそこまでないんだけど
なんとかあるんではないかというところで
我々その品物を買うんです
例えばサントリーがセサミンEという薬作って
もう自分たちで売ってるんだと
あれは何販売でしたっけ？あの
そういう普通の店で売ってないんだと
テレビショッピングでよく見ますからね
これは奇跡だと自分たちが長い間研究してとか
本当かと そんな時間あなた方はやっていたのかと
嘘ばっかりなんですけど
年も研究したんだと しかも何かしらものが年にも研究して作ったんだと
それで嘘ってまるっきりバレますけどね
ただ今 今人間は毒は流行ってますから
もうもう健康にやれと言ったら
だからなんとかなんとか作って売り出してるだけの話ですよ
しかし だからといってセサミンEというのは
この まあこのもう何のことないあのゴマの油なんですよ
油の成分ももうちょっと
ちょっとなんとか改良してるでしょうね
だからゴマの油使ってるところまで
もしかすると本当かも
まあどうせそっちを食べてるものだから死にはせんやと思う
言ってる効果はどうであろうとも
だからそれも日本に法律がある
薬として売る場合はまた法律がある
だからみんな補助食品として売ってる
する補助食品だから食品というカテゴリーに入るんだからね
しかし 食品と言っちゃうと食品でなければいけないという法律がある
それで補助食品にしておく
それがこの嘘言ってはいけないということだから
なんとか命を守っているんですよ
でないと何の商売もできませんよ
銀行にお金を預かりますか？銀行は嘘を言ってもいいならば
もし嘘を言ってもいいんだけど
こちら 100万円預けて次の日それまた欲しくなったところで
あんた誰？誰？と わしは昨日来てお金入れたんですけど
知りません そんなあんたのこと
そうなるでしょうに だから嘘言ってはいけないんだから
我々は安心してお金を銀行に預かるんですよ
まあせいぜい嘘を言ってもいいと言えば
政治家ぐらいですね 政治家の世界では嘘は上手
どちらが上手かということは勝負なんですね
一番上手に嘘をつけて人を国民騙った人が勝つます
まあそれ以外はね 嘘はダメですよ
だから道徳が確実に必要なんです
面白いこと 動物の世界にしたっても
自然に道徳成り立つのだから
自分たちの子孫が繁栄して長生きできるようにということに
それぞれ道徳成り立ってます
例えば鳥たちの中で このすごい見事に魚を捕れる能力ある鳥がいるんですね
海の中でプクプクプクと魚を捕っちゃうんですよ
そこら辺でもう別の種類の鳥も住んでるんです
この崖の上で 下手なんですね
狩りは 水に飛び込むことできない海に
その人々に奪う能力があるんです
だから見てる すごく可愛いんですよ
あの 自分たちがヒナを育てるためにという
一生懸命でっかい魚捕ったりするんです
ものすごい見事に簡単に取るんですよ
取って飛んでくると 奪う魚鳥が来て奪っちゃうんです
奪って自分のヒナに食べさせるんですよ
あれは泥棒でも盗みでもなんでもないんです
そうなっているんです
それで私はこの鳥たちを見ているんです
テレビで番組なんですけど
じっと見ていると 奪われる側は悔しくなるのかと
全然悔しくならないんです
その連中も知ってるんです
これは奪われるんだと
だからいろんな技をしながら泳ぐと飛ぶんですよ
でもこちらサーッと技をして下に行くと
向こうはもうその訓練が知ってるんだから下からヒュッと来てパチッと取っていくんですね
それ聞いたらこの鳥どうするのかというと
何のこともなくそのまま飛んでいって別の魚を取るんです
だから匹取られると 匹目はもうまた食べてるんだからね
持っていって自分のヒナにあげる
だから ああいう奪うよ奪って食べる
あの世界にでもそれなりの決まりが設定しているんですよ
もし奪う鳥たちが無差別にむちゃくちゃ奪っちゃうとどうなるのかというと
漁 漁をやってる鳥たち
みんな死んじゃうでしょう
そうすると自分たちも死んじゃうでしょう
そこまではいかないんです
人間よりはものすごい立派です
強盗してヒナを育てる鳥なんですけど
だからそれは強盗ということにならない
そういう生き方ですね
その動物は その鳥たちは
しかし そちらにもきちんとバランスを整えましょうという
この間テレビで見たんですけど
地面の中に穴を掘って生活するネズミたちで
それプリティドッグとかなんとかっていうね
まあ可愛いんですけどね
で 仲間が餌を食べると
ちゃんと見張りはあって
みんな立って周り見ているんですね
それで見張りやってる人々は見張りやっている
そこで仲間はご飯食べて適当に食べちゃうと
そちらがきちんと見張りをして
また見張りやっていた人とまた餌を食べたりする
そちらに小手が来るんですよ
小手が来ると みんなキャキャキャキャキャキャキャキャと
一応忠告をする 忠告するんだったら
もうサッと瞬時に逃げればいいでしょう
穴の中に 逃げないんですね
小手をバカにするんですね
見てみれば 小手来たんですけど
バカにされてるのをみんなに悪口ぐちゃぐちゃ言われてもわかるんです
そいつは そいつはもうちょっと取ろうとしちゃうと
それで逃げちゃう 逃げる
逃げると本当に負けた
もうしょうがないっていう感じで帰るんですよ
それと こちらすごく威張ってキャーキャーと悪口言ってるんですよね
帰ってる途中でパクッと一匹取って出てくる
だからそちら辺にもやっぱりそれなりのバランスはできてるんですよ
小手に食べられるんだという知っていれば
みんな逃げちゃえばもう穴の中に入っちゃえば取れませんだから
そんなことしたら小手が死んじゃうし
小手怖いと知りながらもちょっとからかってやるぞという
リスもそうなんですよ
えらく猫をからかっちゃうんですよ
結局やられちゃいますけどね
だから今の猫は別にもう狩りをしてもしなくてもいいんですけど
猫は面白いということでね
もうなんとかやってみようと